[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young mom
whose husband is struggling with
depression and she doesn't know what to
do we talk to a dad who's trying to
teach body positivity to his young
daughters and we talk to a guy who's
running a family business and
everybody's leaving and he's taking it
personally stay tuned
[Music]
good morning good afternoon and good
night this is john with the dr john
deloney show
via the truman show hope you're doing
well
hope your families are okay hope you're
okay hope you're better than okay
so glad you're with us on today's show
where we talk about mental health
wellness making good choices
being on time
that's some inside baseball here's today
so far
i uh
got up this morning
it was frosty outside like the snowman
went outside turned the car on so it'd
warm up
then i went to get in it
and i had a flat tire
so great
and so then i had to
get my wife's
race prius
the breeze the the race prius and warm
it up
i'm about to because that's what i was
born to do like crisscross
and
then i got to work late
and when you have a radio show it's not
great because then it starts and then i
got here i didn't have a wedding ring
but i have a backup one in my bag it's
one of those days so i feel like james
you should sing a song
kind of control alt delete and then we
can get going i just want to applaud you
for you you texted and said you're
running late but you didn't give an
excuse which was very valid that you had
a flat tire so
i put flat tire in there didn't i no you
just said it running late
oh
i thought i for sure said why because i
want to be like i'm not just being late
this time well i didn't give you crap so
we're all even
i don't know how i came up on top of
that one but that's awesome awesome
awesome i'll take it so
we're gonna slap it up flip it reverse
it
get our heads and
whatever right all right let's go to
jessica in wilkesboro north carolina
what's up jessica how are you
hey dr john i'm doing
pretty good how are you this morning i'm
good that sounds fantastic uh inside of
baseball we had some uh phone line
issues probably on our part and so now
we are squared up and you sound like a
human that's awesome jessica
okay so you're filling me in you've got
some chaos in your house what's going on
it's eight weeks ago i had twin girls
and
um just a lot of changes there
and my husband's been struggling so i'm
just trying to see how i can help him
out with this very cool so walk me
through
one congratulations on having two twin
girls and you've got two other kids
right so you got a total of four
yeah four girls and the oldest one is
how old
six
wow okay so people email me all the time
on the internets are they they slide
into my dms and they tell me that i say
the words um
you're in it
too much and so i won't say that but you
are super in it man wow okay four six
and under that's a lot okay so how's
your husband struggling
well just we've had a lot of changes
going on this year with the pandemic and
we had deaths in the family of our
grandparents
um the move we moved in the summer
where'd you move from like a new state
or a new town
just a new town yeah we moved um just
about an hour away from where we were
living
okay
oh man i've got a whole thing about that
um okay so
when you say he's struggling what does
that look like
just dealing with some depression like
just anxiety
fear of you know supplying for us
for the family financially
you know just a lot of doubts and
worthlessness feeling you know not
worthy worthy or
um just feeling
like he's not doing a good job gotcha
where does he get that message from
mostly himself i feel like her
you know it's just thoughts that
are being put into his head or
attacks on him that
are coming from
you know
things that
think they're gonna happen but then they
don't end up happening um meaning like
people people are gonna offer him a job
and then they don't come through yeah
okay yeah he has a business that he
started so he'll have a plan and then it
won't you know follow through and he
just gets really discouraged why um
why'd y'all move
we just felt the lord calling us to this
area specifically what does that mean
when you say the lord calls us like what
does that mean
we felt
a really
strong pull to this area it's
it's a prayer
it's called prayer mountain and
we have some land here
and so we have some family that live
here but we just felt that
the road was trying to get us out of the
city life and more into the country life
with you know land and an area where we
could
raise our children
we could
hunt we could you know
be ourselves
we could just
be more free to be us and not have to
live
under that
city type of lifestyle where we're you
know
always
dealing with loud neighbors or
you know things going on that we don't
believe in
my coyotes are pretty loud neighbors too
but i get what you're saying so yeah um
is there
i have some ideas but i i want to get a
sense of what you're living with
um you've got these two little babies
and twins are
a lot and you've got two other little
ones who now were the center of the
universe and now they are
understandably having to wipe their own
bottoms and they don't like that
and yeah a lot of this i'm guessing
because you got a somebody who just is
trying to start a new business in a new
little community
a lot of that falls on you and now you
are also
having a weird task of propping up
a depressed husband
walk me through what that feels like
it's just
it feels hard it feels like you know i'm
taking this day by day um just trying to
make it through the day or you know
make it through the end of the week or
um
but i also feel like
i'm not doing a good enough job or being
you know a good enough spouse for him
like i'm doing my job by raising the
children you know taking care of the
babies feeding them changing them all
those things that come with the
responsibility of being a mother but
also first and foremost you know your
relationship with your spouse has to be
has to be top priority and you have to
make sure that you're you're on the same
level with your spouse and putting them
first what
what's something is different now and
it's making you nervous what is it
there's something there's something
below what you're telling me is what i'm
getting at there's something else yeah
that this is all
new to me like this is all
a change yeah it's a big um
it's a big change and we had full-time
jobs we both worked full-time at our old
um where we lived and things were
comfortable
um
but now things are not so comfortable
and the future looks kind of you know
wish-washy
okay and it looks wish-washy and your
husband thinks he's failing because he's
not making enough money um
because people he can't count on people
because he thought this move to the
country was going to heal everything and
we're it was all going to make what what
does he feel like he's missing
it's just a lot of
like pressure um
he
he had this job that he did for somebody
in their house and now they've come back
and they're not happy or they this is
falling apart or this is this way sure
and he just feels
you know like he's not doing a good job
yeah is it is it honest to say that he
didn't do a good job on that one
no that's not true okay okay anything he
touches turns to gold you know he's very
proud craftsman uh very crafty so
yeah it's it's just
here's a couple of things i want you all
to
keep in your mind and some things y'all
can do
to
kind of
not get through this season but to make
this season something really powerful
and important
and yeah this touch is close to home for
me because i just went through this
about a year ago
moving from downtown downtown i mean it
was bustling it was awesome we were
walking everywhere the city was always
going
to now we live on some acres out in
like the woods woods
um
like coyotes running across the yard
woods
yeah um right
i
i hear this a lot from people who make
this transition that they think whenever
i get there wherever there is
finally things will be okay
and i will be a little less anxious
about the state of the economy and i'll
be a little less anxious about supply
chain issues and i'll be a little less
worried about covet and i'll finally get
out of these dumb schools because then
i'll be able to whatever
and if
we
we play one side of that equation over
and over and we tell ourselves the story
we tell ourselves the story we tell
ourselves a story and then every single
thing we see
backs up our story that we tell
ourselves
every we forget the 50 emails that are
positive that the school sends and they
send the one that makes us crazy and we
go c
and we start looking everywhere for data
points they're going to back up our
story
and then we move
and some and this also works if you're
going in reverse this this is if you're
gonna break up with somebody and get
somebody new or you're cheating on your
spouse whatever the thing is
we think that when we get over there
wherever there is finally things will be
okay
and the worst part about any sort of
transition is that you go with you
and if you were anxious when you lived
in a city you're going to be super
anxious
when you're living out in the middle of
the country
and if you were
didn't like customer interaction you're
really good with your hands and you
didn't like customer interaction your
old job and you can't wait to just do it
on your own well on your own it's all
customer interaction you know i mean so
we miss the good parts we missed the
tough parts we that we just look for the
parts that validate our story
um the second thing that i
underestimated
is it's a lonely out in the country
it's lonely
and i had neighbors i didn't even like
them all but i had them
and there i had one neighbor dogs are
always barking bark and bark they drove
me crazy now it's just silence and their
silence was awesome for a few months and
i kind of missed the dog you know what i
mean so it's a it's a bose and
um but i got really really lonely
um
and then there's this weird thing about
moving an hour away
and here's my little hypothesis about
this there's no research to back this up
i think moving an hour away or 45
minutes away
is really hard
because you tell yourself that things
will mostly be the same
we can still come visit them we'll still
go to this restaurant we'll still go see
these people
because it's just an hour away and you
don't realize there's no chance you're
doing that
and if you move 10 hours away you have
to pack up and move to a new place but
you kind of stretch it out when you move
an hour away is that fair
right yes it's like this it'll be both
and and it's just not and i don't know
you get this this this middle space here
so here's
here i'll just say what me and my wife
have had to do okay
um
one
have you called out his depression
yes and what does he say to that
that he just doesn't feel like it's
something that he could talk to somebody
about um
you know it's not becoming of a man to
to talk about his feelings
kind of thing and what i'll tell you is
it's not becoming of a man to melt your
wife
and it's not becoming of a man to starve
his four daughters of connection and
it's not becoming of a man to be in a
home and not present
and so the most manly thing he could do
would be to go take care of himself
yeah and i'd love for him to call me
because i'll take him to task over that
nonsense
the most
manly thing he could do is take care of
himself
and i work with navy seals behind closed
door i mean to work with some folks
behind closed doors
and
the baddest of the bad
and yeah they take care of themselves
okay so
here's a
here's what y'all have to do that i
don't think you have
you all need to have some sort of and i
know it's almost impossible with two
eight week olds or eight month olds
you have to get
away
even for two hours
and do a here's where we are now
conversation
it sounds like you all ran to a new
world and you didn't stop you just kept
life kept going
and it kept going and it's still trying
to just keep going but everything has
changed
and so if you were in
if you were a navy seal and you had a
mission and you went out on that mission
and all of a sudden your lead humvees
blew up and you found yourself another
you have to stop for a second and say
okay our objective now is different it
was to go get the bad guys now it's to
just get home and our everything's
changed
you all have to have that conversation
and that will look like this
getting out some paper and writing down
here's all the things that i miss about
our old house here's all the things i'm
so glad
that we're away from
here is where i feel like i'm failing
here's where i think i'm doing good you
got to put all that on paper and get it
out of each other's heads and now
there's this there's this tension
between each other because you don't
know how to lean into him
and
because it's i don't know it's like a
little bit reactory it's a little bit
like putting your hand in quicksand and
then he feels that you're not there and
then he feels like he's feeling and this
thing just loops on itself right
and now you are starting to wonder what
am i doing wrong as a wife and
i should be able to say the right thing
that's gonna snap him out of all this
and he should be saying
i shouldn't have a depressed wife that's
my fault and now y'all end up way far
apart so somebody's gotta just say hey
we gotta acknowledge this call it out
write down what sucks about this new
season what we miss what we love
and
you've got to start modeling the only
thing you can do here you can't fix it
let me put it that way you've got to
start modeling i'm taking care of myself
and if that means i'm gonna get a
babysitter that we can't even afford
because i'm gonna go see a counselor i'm
gonna go talk to a pastor that i trust
whatever that looks like i'm gonna go do
that
and here's the thing that
i hope this isn't controversial good
grief who never knows what the
internet's
the reason i i
wanted you to dig in a little bit on
this phrase god's calling us
i hear that a lot all over the country
and two things happen
one
people make big crazy life moves
and they say god told us to
and
they don't take ownership of the fact
that we really wanted to move we want to
get out of there and when we can say
god's telling us to or some some big
universe is calling us whatever that
means
we often don't do the planning required
do we have enough money
do we have a plan do we have any sort of
income are we gonna be able to pay the
light bill
and not to say that um
you know faith isn't uh obviously if
it's important
but we don't do the planning and then
when we show up somewhere and it's
uncomfortable
it melts everything melts our
relationships it melts faith it melts
everything
and so
i have i have no doubt
i i'm never gonna get between you and
your faith ever
but i want you to have faith and plan
like have faith and make really sound
financial decisions in relational
decisions what does that mean
he's trying to get a business off the
ground he may have to deliver pizzas at
night in this new community he may have
to mow lawns and cut down trees too for
a season
and that's not going to feel like quote
unquote i got called to this thing where
i'm grinding but that may be the season
you're in because we got to pay bills
and that's where you're going to get
these little wins and begin to
get our feet underneath us does that
make sense
yeah yeah totally yeah i understand
the big thing is don't just let all of
this change run over you and just try to
get to the next thing you all got to
stop and acknowledge everything you got
to grieve it we missed this stuff we
made a big move this is our new world
and now we can build a new plan moving
forward and that's so so hard
and what's gonna be really hard for you
you're so you're so great what's gonna
be hard for you
is you can't fix him and you can't help
him
i mean you can help him you can love him
you can connect but you can't fix him
he has to make some decisions about him
being well about him gonna maybe let
this dream die for a minute or do this
stream on the side because he's got to
make some money or
maybe
he had these dreams of a big house and
he's gonna have to have a small house
for the next decade and and fill in the
black we have to be honest about those
things and he's gonna have to make the
hard choice to change his thoughts and
to change his actions and be disciplined
in taking care of himself in his
relationships and that's
hard and so i hope he sees this i want
to tell you brother you are worth being
well
you're worth taking care of yourself
and i don't hear any more nonsense about
what's unbecoming of a man
all of that is nonsense the most
becoming thing is taking care of
yourself and being well if you're not
okay you're not okay man i've been there
every guy i know has been there
the courageous thing is the brave thing
is
are we gonna be vulnerable and go get
help
that's the question
jessica he's lucky to have you
y'all get away and start grieving and
then we'll start get you and then we'll
get to making plans in the future we'll
be right back on the dr john deluna show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone's show the world
is bonkers right we all know this and
one of the most common questions i get
is how do i find a counselor in the
chaos i've reached out and there's a six
month waiting list or i can't afford it
or they only take insurance or i can't
get off work and time to go see somebody
it's way across town what do i do
because i want help with my anxiety my
depression my relationships are hanging
on by a thread i want to be a better mom
i gotta process this trauma that
happened to me when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john delaney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
delony
all right let's go out to phoenix
arizona and talk to jacob what is up
brother jacob how we doing man
i'm doing so good john how you doing
doing outstanding and
your phone sounds great this time we're
having all kind of technical
difficulties so good with it it's
probably because i had a flat tire this
morning all of it all right so what's up
brother how can i help man so ultimately
my question i'm going to give you some
examples but my question is going to be
are we putting me and my wife are we
putting too much on our kids um
as far as trying to give them life
experience and should we just be kind of
letting them
run free worry-free a little more
um
this
you were talking about treating people
like dogs the other day
assuming that they have a bad past and
that's why they're having a rough time
so our daughter came to us
and
her she was having a bad day some kid at
school was mean to her okay and we tell
her
you know maybe uh maybe his parents are
mean to him like maybe that's why he's
mean to you and he's just he's scared so
he's acting like that
she comes home the next day and she's
like i told him that his mom is mean and
he said no she's not
and
okay
another example we've always been pretty
direct about body parts we you know what
they're really called stuff like that um
because we figured
kids at school are going to tell her we
want to be the ones to tell her
then we realized she's the one at school
telling the other kids
because we told her and
so and i have i have other examples but
i just
like are we okay one more example we're
at the park the other day this is recent
um
there's a
there's a guy
who's definitely having a psychotic
episode and and i work in mental health
um
and he's he's completely off and we um
so we got to a safe place and i called
the police um but then we sat down and
we told like hey look at look at what's
going on
and i talked to him about that there's
there's bad drugs you can put in your
body that will really hurt you and
this is what it could look like because
i wanted to
i wanted him to have some context for it
not just see this guy going out of his
mind yeah um
how old is how old are your kids
from a
seven-year-old
five-year-old
and a two-year-old they're all girls so
obviously the two-year-old we're not
we're not like putting any of this on
right
so
number one i want to applaud your heart
dude like
the idea that you want to walk with your
kids through the world is such a gift
that's awesome
um
having body positivity is awesome
awesome awesome
um all that man that's good man it's so
good here's
here's an important thing to understand
about a seven-year-old and a
five-year-old
is
they are more emotion than they are
context
yeah and they're more feeling than they
are context meaning when your daughter
comes to you and says a boy is being
mean at school
you and i our default is i want to
provide the explanation there is a sound
in the engine and i want to open up the
glove compartment pull out the little
bot the little
you know the manual and find out what
the noise is and then i want to explain
what's going on there
what a seven-year-old is asking for when
she says that boy was mean
is am i still pretty daddy do you love
me
and so whenever i jump to or whenever
you jump to
well
he's doing this because of this
what that does is that squashes how she
feels and gives her a a explanation for
her feeling it gives her a fix for her
feeling
and what a seven-year-old wants is
validation and connection that's
actually what a 37 year old wants too so
my guess is your wife may come home and
say
today was sucked at work it was so hard
whatever and your response might be
well that's just because you said this
and it's like yeah probably
you know i mean and and
is that true yeah that's true is at kids
mom probably pretty ugly to her possibly
that's not the question that's that
wasn't the the
the entry point for your daughter
and so
um when what what i try to do with my
kids what i recommend people do with
your kids is answer the question before
them
not try to answer questions that aren't
being asked
and so
when your daughter tells you this thing
she's not asking a question on why is
that boy being mean to me
she's asking do you still love me dad
am i pretty
do i have weird hair or whatever that
boy said
that's what she's asking will you
protect me
not why is he being mean to me
is that you hear what i'm saying
yeah and then
oh it hit home because
i was uh i'm seeing with my
five-year-old
tell me about that
oh
it's um
i'm working
i'm a nurse and i'm i'm working in
mental health right now and uh
and i'm going into
um i'm working on my nurse practitioner
for mental health yeah so i see i see
all this
yeah stop kids go through
and my fire
is um
it's like i know
man take your breath brother you're good
take a breath breath take your breath
take your breath you're good
i know we're good parents
dude you're incredible i can tell right
now you're incredible parents yes
my five-year-old it's like
if anything
if anything is just a hair off
it's like she's got this radar and it's
just being and she'll just run over to
you
so like grab you give you a hug so
she'll tickle you try to make you laugh
um
it's like
man she's so sensitive
to any um
any even negative vibe and we have a
me and my wife we don't fight like we we
love each other so much
and
i really think we have a good home we're
not perfect we get frustrated
but it's like i see
i see that
that she
maybe needs to know
in a different way and maybe need to
know more that
that we love her i don't know well i
don't think i don't i think she knows
you love her there's no question about
that
i think there is a possibility and again
i don't know your home man so i'm i'm
i'm just some clown on the radio but
my guess is your five-year-old would
benefit from less facts and more touch
yeah
yeah and there's a moment when a parent
my son is very similar to your daughter
i have to be careful after a long hard
week
like right now dude i am cooked just
tired like it's been a long season i'm
exhausted and we're coming up on the
holidays thing thank goodness
i have to be careful
that i don't lean on my son for support
because he's 11. that's not his job yeah
in his hugs he feels it when i come in
and he will come find me
and he'll say things like i'm so glad
you're my dad
yeah and
he gets that from me because i tell him
every single day of his life of all the
people in the world
god picked me to be your dad and i'm so
grateful for that i let him know that
and now he's learned that language
but now he realize he feels dad's tired
or he sees it on me or dad's anxious or
dad's burnt out
and he knows
oh dad loves hugs and suddenly he takes
it on his responsibility to prop dad up
and that's where that's a problem i've
got to be propped up by people my age
by a counselor by my wife but you know
what i mean not by my kid and it's just
hard because i love his hugs man and i
love his heart now my daughter she's
just like dad you're annoying get out of
here so she just destroys me but um but
he's very similar that way
i
you're not doing it's not a matter of
you're doing something wrong i think
it's just a matter of
getting a new tool in the toolbox so
going to the park
i think what a kid needs to know
is that guy's not is not well he's sick
right he's hurting right
the details over what happens there like
let's let's turn this into a life lesson
right now
imagine you are driving and your car has
just lost control
that isn't the moment to be like well
honey you shouldn't have been driving i
mean because you're about to hit the
guardrail right
yeah that's when you reach over and just
grab her hand
yeah that because and when your
daughter's at a park and somebody's
having a psychotic break
every system in their body goes
haywire
right that's not the moment for the
teaching moment
in a year from now or two years from now
when she says hey dad
what are drugs
now we're in a safe place she she's not
in her limbic system she's in her
frontal lobe she's able to hear and
learn and then you can point back do you
remember
when
um that man at the park
now we can have a teaching moment
but in that moment with at the park what
your daughter's begging for is
the answer to the question are we safe
am i okay
and you are holding her hand you have
made the phone call you know how to
intervene with this man if you need to
that's all she needs because she's not
hearing anything else
other than am i okay am i okay am i okay
and i try to i do i over teach too and i
i like you you're a nurse practitioner
you live in this stuff and you see every
day
what the end result of some of these
early life choices or some of this early
life trauma that people go through who
knows what hell that man's been through
and in his life my guess is drugs make a
lot of sense
for the trauma this guy's endured
and so you and i experience these things
in our jobs and then we want to go like
we want to reverse engineer and teach
everybody that the right like here's the
right path because i know
and a five-year-old can't hear that
now the separate thing is i want to get
to this because this makes me love you
and your wife
it was in grad school that i had a
professor
and dr marble she said
i want everyone in this room
to say penis and vagina over and over
again and she was like say it again and
the i mean there's all like a room full
of 20 adults going penis and then she'd
say again and it'd be like and
everyone's laughing and giggling
and then she called everybody out she
said
if you can't say body part names without
getting flushed or read
if you can't say
oral sex without your like
if you can't do that you cannot work in
the lives of other people and you should
not be a parent
and it was a the whole room got real
quiet
and it was a hundred percent true
and so we have a generation of human
whose parents called it titi or your
little your little woo-woo or whatever
the thing is
or they worse they said nothing they
said nothing or when their kids came in
and they had you know like
a tick and they're like hey will you
look at this mom got all red and dad was
like oh
they just learned
this part of my body is gross
or unsightly or we don't talk about this
and so just
just being able to talk about body parts
of your children
is not gross or weird and you are one of
the few parents that are turning this
thing around this body positivity yeah
dude that's your vagina that's your
penis man you have one i have one too
everyone here has one and man i'm in in
the lobby and so like i'm in a public
like the radio show has got a lobby out
here and you should see everyone in the
lobby just looking being like wow how
many times he gonna say penis a bunch
i'm gonna say it a bunch
your professor would be proud of you
nailed it she would but there's a way to
just i gotta have this conversation you
gotta be able to talk about sex in front
of your kids you gotta be able to talk
about body parts in front of your kids
now here's the magic
i'll tell you what happens at my house i
love fart jokes and i love diarrhea
jokes i love all
bathroom humor body i just love those i
think they're funny i thought tommy boy
is hilarious my wife did not think that
movie was funny at all i think all the
happy gilmore movies are hilarious my
wife doesn't so
it's uh i when i had a little boy all of
my my life was made complete
sure because i got someone to share in
my immature humor with me all the time
and now my daughter's the same so my
wife at some point said john not at the
table
not at the dinner table like enough
and so now my son i'll make a joke and
the whole family be like not at the
table dad
and here's
underneath all that is time and place
so when it comes to
using body positive yes
and saying
these are private parts and we talk
about this here at home with mom and dad
we
the same as only mom and dad are allowed
to see your private parts your mom and
dad or a doctor when mom and dad is in
the room
and this is all just common language
and
like this is no i'm not getting flushed
my heart rate isn't going up in debt
this is just regular language just
regular talk
they feel that honest when every time
dad
comes to help me in the shower does he
look all weird does he avert his eyes
from my little body
is he uncomfortable whenever i have a
tick on you know
all my testicles does my dad go
or does he just like approach it as
though i've got a cut on my toe you know
you know what i mean it's so they pick
up that from us
and then it's very fair it's appropriate
it's important to say we don't talk
about that at school we don't talk about
our private parts at school
that's between conversations here
and so it's both and
how does that land with you guys
it's
it's good and it helps i mean it
clarifies i i mean i feel more
comfortable with the the body language
talk and i feel like we're on the right
page with that but um you really you
really got punched me with the they want
to know that they're safe they don't
want to know facts in that in that
moment gotcha so that was good if they
want to know facts
there's a difference between that man's
a drug addict and he's got this and this
and this and this and this versus that
man sick
right and as we get older you know the
the
the
now my son's 11 i explain much more to
him now and then when he's 16 i'll
explain much much more to him and so on
and so forth
um
yeah let's answer the questions they're
asking but dude hey you're doing a great
job man
you and your wife y'all should high five
each other
and
if you've been a nurse the last 24
months you're probably exhausted brother
probably exhausted i just want to let
you know i can't let you get off the
phone without telling you you're worth
being well too man
you're worth being well too we'll be
right back on the doctor john the
winning show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and then
i'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back
listen if you're about to buy a home and
make a big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan two hundred trust me that's triple
eight loan two hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right let's take one more let's go
to jace in
columbia missouri what's up jace
hey how are you doing remarkable brother
how are you
i'm doing great cool so what's up dude
so um i am the general manager of a 40
year old family carpet cleaning business
um i'm third generation and it's what i
wanted to do my entire life as long as i
can remember it's so cool man
yeah uh i've been back as a general
manager for the last i guess four years
in january
and i'm going through a season where it
feels like everyone is leaving
oh yeah
yeah
one guy i was pretty close with
a couple weeks ago left with two days
notice um why uh
he said it was money
um that worked kind of seasonal but it's
been something that i've been working on
since i've been back
um didn't give me a lot of explanation
but when he told me i was more in shock
mode than i was to like try and dissect
it
um
yeah
and then
uh
um no one's
he's the only one that's left so far
there's another one that has told
or intends to leave in the next month or
so once again citing uh money or more
consistent hours that kind of stuff yeah
um and then i've heard
rumors and rumors um from
one of the guys that's been with us for
26 years um
about some of the other guys that have
been talking about not being around in
the in the next like couple quarters
probably
so
in a family business
something you've wanted to do your whole
life
this feels real personal doesn't it
yeah they're not quitting a job for a
dollar an hour they're leaving
like they're leaving you
yeah there's been some of that you know
i wanna i wanna tell you
i'm glad this is keeping you up that
means you're a good leader
that means your heart's in the right
place so good for you
it's good if you were like well screw
you i'll go then i would
tell you you probably shouldn't be
leading people so the fact that this is
sitting in your soul and it hurts a
little bit that's good i'm glad that's
happening okay i'm not i'm not happy for
your discomfort but i'm glad that that's
your disposition you care about this
thing
and so
a couple of things i want you to think
about
one is
facts are your friends
are they right
and anytime somebody says i'm i'm don't
want to be around you because you're a
jerk or whenever we have team meetings
and james says
when you are late john
here's how this affects everybody else
uh first thing i have to ask is is he
right
he is he's right and so when you hear
people saying about money this the money
that what
what are they right
have they gotten disconnected from the
family mission which is
we are helping people
we're not just cleaning carpets we are
taking care of people have you taken
this guy that that you were close to
that just quit on two days notice
there's something else going on there
because friends i mean connected people
don't do that to each other
and so
have you taken him out for coffee just
or grab a beer and be like all right so
you're gone cool we're cool
tell me like what really is going on
because that's not something people do
even jerks give two weeks notice you
know what i mean
so i'll ask you what what are the facts
here are do they have a point is what
they're saying true
um
i don't yeah i don't know i haven't
talked to him much since since he left
and that's probably a misstep on me i
just
i don't know
yeah it's new it's grief i mean
make the next right step right i mean
don't don't go backwards just make the
next right step yeah
um but no they're
i
know
i think a lot of the guys that work for
us and being service
industry they
they see the world through a very short
term lens so we are very seasonal um so
we're working a lot of our work is in
the summertime so they're working i mean
some of them are working 60 hours a week
for a short period of time
and like that's where
uh you make your money but when they
spend that all throughout the rest of
the year
then it gets real tight this time of
year when i can basically guarantee them
30 to 35 hours a week gotcha gotcha yeah
so
as a leader
it's really easy to
look at them and blame them for how they
handle their money or for not planning
right or there's too short term or
whatever
what i would love to see you do is to
offer solutions and opportunities for
them
one of those may be
a i want to call a staff like an all
team meeting we're gonna have dinner and
we're gonna talk through some things i'm
gonna give y'all an opportunity to be
heard
like what's going on in your hearts and
minds we've had a crazy 24 months i may
be missing something y'all maybe like
walk me through what your life has been
like
give them an opportunity to fill out
like a questionnaire or to raise their
hands and just listen and you can tell
i'm not going to say anything i'm just
going to listen tonight and i'm gonna
pay for dinner i'm gonna pay y'all for
the two hours you're here
like tell me what's going on in your
world and then from that conversation
you might get
um
here is like if you work 60 hours these
four months and you work 35 hours these
other eight months your total at the end
of the year is 45 thousand dollars
here's how we can here's like ramsey's
the company i work for has a a money
tool for businesses just like that they
just help people over the arc of a year
in their with their smart dollar product
right it's an hr product
is there a product you can help with or
is there a i'm gonna teach budgeting
classes on the weekend or i'm going to
also create another does anybody have
another idea for a business in the off
months and listen to those customers
i'll pay a thousand dollars
in cash for the person who comes up with
the
uh the new opportunity for the offseason
is that you but you're bringing them
along and suddenly they've got purpose
they're a part of this thing they're not
just carpet cleaners
yeah
and for you this is a family business
this is third generation i've always
wanted to do this thing
you've got to understand they don't have
that investment right now and i'll blame
you the leader you got to give him that
investment
so then so the other wrinkle being i
mean i'm just
for lack of a better work term word or
whatever um just more so middle
management so i got my dad and uncle are
co-owners and they're the operations
there
and
i feel like i'm in a sometimes in a
cycle of
like asking for kind of a vision and a
leadership and not leadership but just a
vision of like where we're going or like
when is the transition like how what
does that look like all that kind of
stuff
and
it leads to frustration and then i mean
obviously i bring that home yeah home
life and all that kind of stuff so that
when you ask for those questions they
just won't answer you or they say i'll
talk about later
it's one of those things it's like
yeah it's not the most pressing issue
how much do you make a year
me
what's your take home
my
take home is this year going to be 75
okay
here's what i want you to do and this is
going to sound bonkers
okay
i want you just to for the first time
maybe in your life
i want you to survey your area where you
live
and see how many jobs are between
sixteen eighty thousand dollars for a gm
of a successful carpet company cleaning
company
is there other service oriented jobs
and here's why i'm telling you that
your family is not worth this
your heart and soul is not worth this
and if you've got two family member
owners who won't tell you what the
future is going to look like won't catch
the vision and won't let you do that
what i'm going to tell you is you're
going to end up bitter and exhausted and
chasing people and you're going to end
up cleaning the carpet at 2am because
you've got no workers
and you're going to have no say on
anything
and your family isn't worth that and you
are worth more than that
and i'm not telling you to leave i'm
telling you right now you're starting to
i can hear it in you you're starting to
feel trapped
and when we get trapped we make dumb
decisions yeah we do
that's when we respond to that girl's
text
that's when we have one too many drinks
and we get in a car or we just do stupid
stuff that's when we yell at our wife or
our kids and we didn't mean to that's we
just do don't we go buy a car that we
don't need
we just do dumb stuff am i on the right
track
yeah no that makes sense i haven't
thankfully haven't gotten to that point
where i've done dumb stuff but i feel
like i've been in this cycle of you're
on the road that's i'm trapped but
every six months or so i sit down with
my dad it's like that bent up
frustrations and yes we handle things
when they're at an eight or nine rather
than dealing with things when they're at
a one or two
now dude the fact that you have that
language is incredible
so the goal now is this i want you to
have
i want you just to survey the area and
not feel trapped you might look around
and be like dude the highest paying job
is 41 000 and that's it like i'm kind of
in this job
my guess is with your experience and
your character
and your drive there's going to be some
opportunities for you especially now
right now especially in the service
sector
i want you to get look around
and i know this has been your lifelong
dream and it may be your lifelong career
and it may not
so i want you to at least go look
and when you have some
huh there's an opportunity over there
that might be kind of awesome and
they're going to give me full reign and
i'm going to make 140 000 a year i'm
gonna have to work like crazy
but i'll get to make some leadership
decisions i'll get to honor some of
these people i'll get to have
conversations about dollars per hour and
whatever
my life would be better that's when you
sit down with your
old man and you say
here's how this is about to go i'm gonna
leave or this and then he gets to make
grown-up boundary decisions
but right now he's acting like a child
and he's treating you like he's
like you still live in his house
like you're a child and you're not
you're a grown man
with your own family
and i still think you
get all of your people together you pay
him for two hours and you serve him
dinner and you say i just want to take a
state of the union how is everybody
and as a general manager you're allowed
to do that
and if your father or
uncle say you're not
you're not having dinner with those that
that crew they're just the workers then
you quit
you go find another job because that
tells you all you need to know there's
no way they're gonna do that
but i think you should then listen to
your team
and you begin to paint a vision of
y'all we're not just cleaning carpets
we're helping families
we're helping people save their home
we are helping fill in the blank we're
taking care of people we have a purpose
and y'all are a part of that purpose and
by the way anybody comes up with the
offseason business
cash i'll give you cash
and now man people aren't gonna leave on
two days notice i want you to take that
guy out though also take that guy off
for coffee and just be like all right
brother go grab a beer and say
where are we at man where are we at
what happened what happened how can i be
better
thanks for the call jace you're awesome
brother
all right uh as we wrap up today's show
man i asked my son this morning
hey hank what's your favorite song you
get song of the day today on the show
he picked
the sixth single
that went number one for the one and
only g garth brooks
nothing like an 11 year old telling you
his favorite song is
thunder rolls
but i got
cheating on his wife
man
whenever you think i should send in my
application for dad of the year my son
comes through
here's the sun the song my 11 year old
son son picked
it goes like this
3 30 in the morning not a soul in sight
and the city's looking like a ghost town
on a moonless summer night rain drops on
the windshield there's a storm moving in
he's heading back from somewhere that he
never should have been
and the thunder rolls and every light's
burning in a house across town she's
pacing by the telephone and her faded
flannel gown asking for a miracle hoping
she's not right praying it's the weather
that's kept him out tonight and the
thunder rolls she's waiting by the
window and he pulls into the drive and
she rushes out to hold him thankfully
he's alive but on the wind and rain a
strange new perfume blows and the
lightning flashes in her eyes and he
knows that she knows
and the thunder rolls and this is not a
song for 11 year olds right here on the
dr john delaney show